Greetings to all of you Fellow Scholars
out there this is Two Minute Papers where
I explain awesome research works, a
couple minutes at a time.
You know, I wish someone explain to me in simple terms
what's going on in genetics, biology and
just about every field of scientific research.
There are tons of wonderful
works coming every day that we don't
know about, and I'm trying my best here
to bring it to you the simplest way I
possibly can. So you know,
researchers are people and physics
research at the Hadron Collider
basically means that people smash atoms
together.
Well, computer graphics people also like
to have some fun and write simulation
programs to smash together a variety of
objects in slow motion.
However, even though most of these
simulations look pretty good
they are physically not correct as many
effects are neglected such as simulating
plasticity, bending, stiffness, stretching,
energies and many others.
But unfortunately, these are too expensive to
compute in high resolution, unless you
have some tricks up the sleeve.
Researchers at UC Berkeley have managed
to crack this nut by creating an
algorithm that uses more computational
resources only around regions where
cracks are likely to happen.
This new technique enables the simulation of
tearing for a variety of materials like
cork, foils, metals, vinyl and it also
yields physically correct results for glass.
Here's an example of a beaten-up rubber
sheet from their simulation program
compared to a real-world photograph.
It's really awesome that you can do something
on your computer in a virtual world that
has something to do with reality.
It is impossible to get used to this feeling,
it's so amazing. And what's even better
since it is really difficult to know in
advance how the cracks would exactly look
like they have also enhanced the directability
of the simulation, so artists
could change things up a bit to achieve
a desired artistic effect.
In this example they have managed to avoid
tearing a duck in two by weakening the
paths around them.
Bravo!
Thanks for watching and if you
liked this series just hit the like and
subscribe buttons below the video to
become a member of our growing club of scholars.
Thanks, and I'll see you next time!